and Newsweek says Alzheimer's disease
could one day be diagnosed with an eye
test after new research showed changes
in the blood vessels in the eye an
estimated six million Americans live
with Alzheimer's disease but one survey
shows that more than 50% of couples
dealing with the condition have not
discussed their wishes related to having
another relationship this was
highlighted when the husband of
lifestyle expert B Smith revealed he was
in a second relationship while he cared
for her it was a set of circumstances
that our Barry Peterson is very familiar
with and you're now sharing with us very
good morning good morning to all of you
my relationship with Alzheimer's is
personal 14 years ago
my late wife Jan was diagnosed with
early onset Alzheimer's during part of
that time I also had another woman in my
life
we called ourselves a family of three
the parallels to B Smith her husband Dan
Gatsby and his girlfriend are uncanny
but it's an all-too-familiar tale for
couples dealing with Alzheimer's one
where love can be complex and
unconventional what's your dad's name my
dad Barbara Smith he's Barbara Smith B
Smith lifestyle guru and restaurateur
developed early onset Alzheimer's six
years ago and until Nikhil and today
husband Dan Gatsby is caring for his
wife of 27 years Wendy and I realized
what we're dealing with and she
understood what the situation is she
said to me I know what I have I know
where it's gonna take me tell the story
tell the truth in January he spoke that
truth and let cameras into his home a
home he shares with his wife and his
girlfriend Alex Lerner who also has a
bedroom in the house and helps with
Bea's care if he wanted to have a
relationship Alex you could have chosen
a lot easier paths yes that's true why
this one I met Dan when he was pretty
much at its lowest
I remember going through her time in my
life where I felt that way where I was
where I was pretty much at my lowest
and I saw the pain in his eyes I did and
I reached out and thought maybe this man
just needs somebody to talk to you know
or as humans sometimes we just need a
hug it was natural it was organic it was
not intentional but we fell into each
other
she still know who you are she will call
me Dad she will call me her brother Gary
or brother Ron then she'll say Dan out
of nowhere and then I said who Dan he's
over there
there may be something in her mind that
says that but then it's gone it's like
trying to drink water from a colander no
matter how much you bring it to you
there's nothing there something I
experienced with my wife Jan after
almost 25 years together she was in
assisted living and no longer remembered
my name
what's his name mr. mr. happy became
Jan's friend it broke my heart that a
man who could love this woman so much
couldn't remember she could not remember
who he was a year and a half after Jan
passed away Marion Illinois got married
the hardest thing for me is people who
don't know but decide that they can
judge what I'm doing please I mean we've
got the 800-pound gorilla in the room
she's white and I'm black so many people
jump to conclusions and judgment that
don't even understand what Alzheimer's
is and what it does to a person to the
patient the Alzheimer's patient as well
as the caregivers so respect what you're
saying and respect you guys in what
you're going through because it's a
definition of love and nobody
understands what a caregiver goes
through I write for a couple hours every
day it restarts the brain Greg O'Brien
has Alzheimer's a lifetime journalist
he's written a book about what he calls
embedded in Alzheimer's he and Mary
Katharine raised three kids
over there 42 year marriage she's gone
from life to caregiver do you know a
date of this not sure people think that
caregiving is a daytime event oh yeah
it's a it's an all-night event how do
you recharge how do you Russ I say one
eye open and one ear open yeah I had a
live in a nightmare and a Daymare
everything I have to do is to mitigate
her everyday irrationality because she
doesn't have that ability maintain her
dignity and try to keep my sanity this
disease Rob's everything it robs your
brain slowly like a sliver every day my
brain is like an iPhone now it's it's
still a sophisticated device but it has
a short-term battery it pocket dials and
it gets lost very whole yeah I try to
say to people who have been critical of
our relationship you are one diagnosis
away from knowing what your life will be
an hour to try even though Greg is still
your functioning we were the house that
had the Super Bowl parties and the
Patriots and unrest and we were the
house that everybody came to a party
house the priming we just did 30 or 40
people summertime deck parties he can't
do that anymore so our social life has
really narrowed down to our very very
clear people run away from you yeah it's
not comfortable sometimes to be around
them what do you want for Mary Catherine
in the future I want her to be happy I
want her to marry a better person than
me and I want her to be at peace I just
don't want her to marry someone who's
handsome that's what you said Greg is
what my wife said to me I want you to go
on because if you truly love someone you
don't own them and what you said is the
true to me expression of love
mr. Gregg asked if we would now that we
know you if we would watch out for you
any entries yes yes definitely found
only yes so the question for everybody
at this table is have you had to talk
because you need to do it when you're
young enough to discuss this because by
the time the person you love is
diagnosed with Alzheimer's it's already
too late hmm it's such a very powerful
story Barry that you're sharing and I
think it's so important for people to
consider it a lot of people judges Gregg
said they judge and they don't know I
know Dan and I've met Alex and she's
really lovely and very dedicated to to
helping Barbara get through all of this
but so I'm so glad that you told their
story what was your take on them as a
couple the way that Dan really has
devoted himself to Barbara in a very
very huge way well I think that let's
give credit to Alex because she came
into this relationship she's now a co
caregiver you know he said he did it
because you vowed that he would tell the
truth but there's one other thing that's
important the fact that he's willing to
talk about it in this way means a lot of
other people who are in this situation
say oh my god I'm not alone yeah he's
taking care of Barbara Wyn if she's wait
when the disease is really progressed
isn't that unusual to way past when I
would have been capable of taking care
of jam I had already made the decision
to put Jen into assisted living
but it's 24 hours I cannot stress how
much this is you never really sleep yeah
and I just have such admiration for his
doing this but I don't want him to do it
to the point where you get sick how
important and helpful are these bonds
because it seemed like it really was
even just watching this piece between
the couples well I think between Dan and
Alex and obviously between myself and
Mary now I think these are life-saving
relationships I mean literally they keep
you from
falling under and dying so I've talked
about this for a very long time and I
say to people listen you can't help the
person who has the disease because we
don't have a cure so help the person
who's the caregiver because they're the
ones who are struggling to survive and
what I don't judge when you're not in
that situation and I think that's a very
important message to send
we made a presentation one time to a
group among the many professional
caregivers and one came up afterward and
said you know what never occurred to me
I only do this for eight hours and I get
to go home Wow very thank you you're
very very welcome thank you